(Latin rumba music)
- [Voiceover] This is
the Chicken Maharaja.
I guess it's like their Big Mac.
Must be.
- There's a lot of bun here.
- Oh my god.
- I don't think this is
the same sauce they use
in a Big Mac, it can't be.
- It's chicken, it's not
beef, but what can you do.
- This is amazing.
This is American opulence
exported to India at its finest.
Like yeah, let's just put all
of it in there, what the hell.
- It's actually a lot
better than I thought.
- [Voiceover] So here we
have the McAloo Tikki burger,
aloo is potato, so I'm
assuming it's gonna be
a lot of potato in here.
- It's got the McDonald's
quality I've come to learn
to, uh..
- Well, it looks like a
burger in the US, kind of.
- It's a little sad looking.
- Don't know what that tastes like.
- It's got some good, you know,
good flavors that I associate with India.
- What's interesting
about this is that it's
absolutely no idea what is in this.
And the inside of the patty is green,
the sauce is orange, and
it's covered in onion.
Like, you know.
- There's so many vegetarians
in India, obviously,
they have to make some veg product.
- Fifty cents, that's a good deal.
- [Voiceover] This is the
big Spicy Chicken Wrap.
- This is American size. (laughs)
- It's confusing, how to...
- I think it's like,
Oh.
- It's actually pretty close
to what it is in the US.
It's a bit more spicy, but...
- Again, there's all the
sauces and mayos, it's so much.
- This might actually
be the spiciest thing
I've ever eaten at McDonald's.
And it's like this
creeping one that's like
coming up the back of my mouth.
- [Voiceover] This is a
100% Paneer Passion McSpicy.
- I still love that they put the "Mc"
in front of everything.
McPaneer, okay.
- Kinda looks like a
deep-fried French toast.
- Is this just a giant hashbrown?
- The cheese, I guess it's a cheese patty?
- And we've got the McDonalds India token
mysterious orange sauce.
- Oh wow, that's spicy.
- (coughs) Oh, there's the spice!
- This is food that you
would just eat in bed
at like, three in the morning.
- The paneer's a little
weird, but I guess it's
kinda like tofu in that way, it just
takes on the flavor of
whatever's on top of it.
- This is something I
think could possibly be
successful in the US.
- I feel like McDonald's India
was literally put together
by someone just perusing
a Wikipedia article
for Indian food, and putting
a "Mc" in front of it.
(rumba music)